22 heures
le premier appel de la soirée pour le
groupe d'appui de nuit direction le
quartier voit deux villes ou des
nuisances sont signalés ainsi qu'une
exhibition d'armes sur place une arme et
bien retrouvé dans le véhicule
quatre individus sont interpellés
très rapidement les trois voitures de
police quitte les lieux leur crainte est
prise à partie c'est un espace go pour
rester dans la cité comme ça bon ben
c'est pas la peur mais c'est toujours
des mesures de sécurité c'est un risque
l'espagne s'est imposée par fab oui
pas plus tard que hier vous avez vu
allongé les belles vues
on a subi des caillassages les quatre
individus sont escortés jusqu'à l'hôtel
de police de fort-de-france et après la
fouille du véhicule deux armes dont une
factice ainsi que du cannabis ont été
découverts
ces agents travaillent exclusivement de
nuit leurs interventions sont de plus en
plus difficile ils dénoncent une
recrudescence des violences à leur égard
on observe de plus en plus d'actes
d'incivilité un votant contre
surtout c'est un poème qui est sociétale
de façon les gens ils ont souvent des
désaccords avec la société et qui voit
arriver basse et la police donc on fait
face avec avec nos moyens qui sont pas
toujours proportionnel à ce qu on se
compte ce qu'on a devant nous le
montrent et ont fait face avec nos
moyens
des moyens qui ne sont plus à la hauteur
de leur mission tant d'un point de vue
humain que matériel véhicules en panne
manque de personnel et des agents qui
doivent parfois acheter eux mêmes leur
lampe torche
un comble pour ces brigades de nuit